okay here we are for another design
review part of uh
wolf language version 13.3
and we are looking here at well I don't
know where this discrete computation
because this seems to be well this is a
discrete computation team yeah but okay
we label the meeting differently we're a
little that's discrete there's very
little it's computation but nevertheless
okay so AR deploy
um
it's interesting that we were just
talking about service deploy which is
probably not unrelated to this
so
the basic idea is this
that you can
use your phone as an AR device to walk
around a 3D object
and the way we do that is this is kind
of new which is a file format that's
emerging to represent AR and VR content
which is this USD
format
and on Android it's so far gltf we
expect those guys to eventually migrate
to USD as well
the way it works so those are two new
file formats that we support and those
are rich file formats
and the second so I just did this and
it's now got I've now got a teapot
sitting
on top of my visual scene isn't that
nice
it's very very cool
wasn't just plain gray right so we're
coming to that so that means that you
don't really necessary so you don't
necessarily need to sort of buy a 3000 I
don't know how to get rid of the teapot
no you have stuck with a teapot now
forever
it's like one of those floaters in your
eye yes now it's a teapot okay all right
so you see since you try this and and
for those
you probably will get up a teapot too I
don't think it's restricted
right it was deployed
okay
but now okay this is exactly what
service deploy is supposed to deal with
because what you have here one of the
issues you have here you've got your QR
code that came back but you also have a
cloud object that's the backup for that
right and and the question is where is
that cloud object and how do you find
the cloud object you know if you wanted
to uh you know what I'm saying if you
want to um I mean you can always export
if you want to sort of have the file the
backing file
but Charles do you there's something
else you want to say but the problem is
that you if you wanted to delete that
instance right how do you do that
So when you say delete the instance you
mean the cloud object yes the backing
Cloud object because that's exactly the
same as you with mail receiver function
and other service deployments
I mean one of the easiest yes one of the
easiest ways just to do bar recognize
and then you get back the cloud object
and then you delete it as any other
object
foreign
literally we're just talking about
things related to this
um
warmed up you know
well or is it mostly problems no no we
have Solutions but that okay they're
somewhat complicated and they're more
programmer or I mean this is beautiful
what you have here
okay
what we figured that we can use the
cloud for something
I'm not even gonna
I'm trying to dignify that with an eye
roll
[Laughter]
um no but but look here's a solution
potentially you've got a print form here
okay
this is the and what I might suggest is
that AR deploy returns a thing which is
some kind of AR deployment
which would look almost exactly like
this but with some additional wrapping
around the QR code
and that if you just want the plain
image of the QR code it's a sub-value to
AR deployment
just as the cloud object will be a sub
value to the AR deployment
do you see what I'm saying no did you
follow this Charles wait so you want the
air deployed to actually generate an
object maybe we can call also air deploy
objects that's what I saw what I heard
too but that means it's going to be a
two-stepper no no it isn't no it doesn't
no it isn't watch this okay okay so so
my point is
where am I saving this
well that's not what I want to save
anyway
I wanted to save this okay well in any
case
um
what I'm suggesting is that it return an
hour deployment
and that they are deployments print form
contains the QR code
right so there's somebody oh I see what
you're saying
oh that's a good idea
so then that gives us a handle to a
bunch of other things exactly so we can
do all kinds of that's not a bad idea
right because then you could also
extract the 3D Graphics you could do
that yep
um
I'm I'm wondering
I think this is very cool what what else
is kind of like this
and and then I'm going to ask questions
about how do I get color on the on the
thing that's on right so
in general
I'd like us to kind of do
more publish you know um it's called
they are publish
yeah maybe
let's talk yeah we do need to talk a bit
about names
and so in general like for all of our
teams I'm looking actively looking for
ways that we can publish more into sort
of the digital ecosystem around us
because it makes it more useful for
everybody if you can get things out and
if you can basically publish and deploy
right but this is look service deploy
just so you're clear what is it
it's for lodging things into external
services
for example a plugin for chat GPT
for example a Discord bot
but it's it's
basically an API right isn't it no no no
listen to what it is okay listen what is
it's something slightly different from
that there is an external service
for example a mail server
okay what you are doing is you're
lodging something with the mail server
so that when you poke the mail server
saying I'm sending mail to this mail
address
then something is activated
the back end is in the cloud activating
in the cloud
does that make sense so let's talk about
Discord bot for example
you talk to the bot whatever it's called
the Wolfie bot or something right
and
that goes through discord's
infrastructure
right and then it calls back with a web
hook or some other such thing so Discord
is some company or some other service or
something
okay slack rocket chat whatever
something that you've heard of okay
telegram okay
um okay so any one of these things you
will or or Alexa for that matter you're
lodging in their infrastructure
something that you will get to with some
name that you you tell to their
infrastructure okay you have a lodged a
thing in their infrastructure that then
says okay if if you got to this place go
out and call this thing which is an API
in our cloud
right
okay so it's a slightly richer
interaction than what you need for this
case here yeah yeah
definitely
um
but I don't think it's uncommon there's
a scenario to described for service
deploy
I can see from a you know for a bunch of
things where you kind of knit things
together yes where the where the
external service
is the exposure point
yeah
see what I'm saying
now what you've got here is a you know
there's three levels there's export to a
file
right where where it's just like the
file is exposed through the file system
or whatever else
[Music]
so in the end what what that QR code is
doing is it's just going to a cloud
object right
right plus or minus depending of 50
Cloud object is actually script or just
a pure link to the file yep
but what is it in this case well in
since you know we don't know if you have
a you know either an iPhone or I mean
iOS or iPad or Android so you have a
code which run behind the scene to
detect the type of device you have what
kind of car is it JavaScript or what uh
no just the normal Wolfram code we just
push right here you're looking at the
the the the
um when the what is it called the the
user agent uh okay yeah right
okay
well I'm
why is this thing not
so okay but so what is that thing behind
behind it if I if I do a if I take this
and I say where did I put my and I just
say
you know barcode recognize of this
what's happening
what's it doing oh
what's this well I mean we won't ship it
with that but
okay but I mean this is ultimately
just a uuid right yes
and what's the slash main
um so by default on the temporary the
height we create another subdirectory I
mean it contained the main script right
when you deploy it on the cloud which
detect it
so if you specify for example that is
you know you know that on your on on iOS
so we deployed the actual files so you
don't have actually domain but you have
a link to the actual USD file
okay what the hell just happened I did a
system open on this thing here and I
just went to the walton.com home page
right so is that part of Auto detection
of the you know the browser you have so
if you're on desktop
I just could not go to the home page it
should go to a page that says use this
on a phone exactly so that was used to
be a designed page
yep so that's temporary for now yeah
who's project managing here
I am Marcy okay so that's the thing that
needs to get done is that page it should
just say
it should just have a you know simple
explanatory page
do you think you guys agree
yeah got it
um
I mean it can just be a cloud object
page just a very simple page but it
should be designed
okay
so you've got just got a uuid here and
there's no identification of what
there's no dot something rather file
type for this is that correct
because you may need different ones
you know Android wants gltf
iOS the word main at the end there
you've you've decided that it's called
main is that correct that could be
anything we want yes okay so I think
that should have a name like AR
dispatcher
but which makes it less obscure to
people what the heck's going on
okay yeah that's what I'm saying so what
should that name be
AR asset AR dispatcher
[Music]
really I don't have any then let's make
it our dispatcher it's a little long but
but um okay so now this will normally be
going into your
Anonymous it's an anonymous Cloud object
in your Cloud file system correct yes
but what if you wanted to you know what
I I don't think this is right I think
what we should do instead is that this
should be something more like Cloud
publish
maybe I'm not sure because the whole
point is I might want to say
what the name of the file that I want to
put this in is
what I'm saying because I might want
this to be put into teapot in my cloud
you know I might want to send somebody
an email a thing that says teapot and
says
you know
you know just because if I got that URL
right and got that on my phone in email
it would have the right Behavior am I
not am I correct
um yes
but mate
and I mean my assumption was that I mean
if somebody really want to start to
customize right you know so AI deployed
do the you know the whole Automation and
such
but you know we hope that's in the
documentation we just easily show
someone like you just do you know
you know Cloud export
of the actual teapot has a USD the cloud
object you get there is exactly pretty
much this no no no it's not exactly
pretty much this it's not it because it
doesn't have the dispatcher framework
right right
okay so that's no good right so what we
have and this is nice I think what we
want
is that you would say cloud publish
of AR dispatcher
of the thing right because it is very
much like URL dispatcher
like you know what URL dispatcher does
right
URL dispatcher takes
um
you see it takes URL patterns and
content
you see what I'm saying
yes
so this is very much the same thing
um
let's see view dispatcher I'm I'm almost
thinking that this could be I mean maybe
this is wrong but something like view
dispatcher
actually this is very similar to it's
like a device dispatcher
hold on hold on hold on this is
incredibly similar to what we've had to
do
in
the framework for dealing with CSS
right so
do you know what I'm talking about there
so you know the stuff that okay so
see let's hope that this is
here we go
all the stuff here
okay interface switched defines a despot
responsive interface for deployed web
pages
okay
so what this is doing
is not by device but by size of web page
right it's doing responsive design type
stuff
does that make sense
yeah
so what you have here is incredibly
similar
I mean
it's very similar to interface switched
what you want here
right you want to say
I mean it's something like
foreign
but it isn't quite this but then what
you want is just Graphics here correct
yes so in in your expression which can
be moved to a graphic yes pretty much
so okay hold on hold on hold on so I
agree it would be nice to have a single
function that does this and produces
this air deployment
that the AR deployment
is a cloud object
hold on the air deployment contains the
whole thing so
help me out here I mean you understand
what the issue is right because we want
two things we want a simple
I think the main thing you're after is
the customizability as I read
well I want customizability I want
deletability
yeah right
so we get deletability with AI
deployment
yes so I'm also concerned about having
about being able to put this
to you know the teapot
you know clearly AR deploy can have a
second argument which is the standard
you know thing that you would do to
deploy to a non-default yes
now I mean you know what really
look let me show you something let me
remind you of something if you Cloud
publish this
okay and I say automatically assign URL
like Cloud publish it
okay look at that there's a barcode
there
it makes me wonder
whether basically we should always
display the how it's a mess to always
display the bar barcode in a
yeah okay this is a separate thing this
is for Marcy to Chase
in a cloud object
we should probably have a sub value to
any Cloud object that says barcode
or QR code or whatever
am I making sense
did you understand what I said do I need
to repeat
understood
okay
so that goes to the cloud object team
which is probably Joel Klein I think
got it hey well I hope you oh there it
is okay I knew we had two ways of
showing um
Cloud on web pages so there's the iframe
but there is the the second one there is
what I've been looking for yes
okay embedding yeah yes
right that's the that's the notebook and
better
okay
what do you want that for
no I just couldn't remember what it was
I knew we had it but I couldn't find it
okay fine
just it seems to you know not been lost
or I couldn't find it
right
okay
so
right okay
this shouldn't be called AR deploy
anyway should we call the AR publisher
that's what it is
see what I'm saying because it has
permissions
see this is a mess
it's a mess because you know imagine
this is the the next stealth fighter or
something you don't want to publish it
to the to the whole world probably
you know what I'm saying
so AR deploy isn't the right thing
because because that is a it's doing a
publish with permissions to public isn't
it
and if it isn't it's doing the wrong
thing
because we have Cloud publish and Cloud
deploy Cloud deploy by default goes only
to your account
right and yeah that's why we went with
you know air deploy instead of AR
publish it always go to your own account
I know this is often not what you want
so I have to say even though it's really
cool to have just one function I kind of
think it will be better to begin with to
have Cloud publish or Cloud deploy and
you have all the same options you have
all the permissions you have all those
kinds of things
and then the question is what's inside
it
but you see that's not going to work
either because we need a return thing
that's an AR deployment
guys you know what this is
we're about to do make a mistake here
okay I think we have the wrong people on
this meeting
um
let's see
who will be the best person
can mostly please ping
uh maybe Joe Klein is the right person
for this
um and also Todd Gailey can you see if
he's around please yes
uh all right let's let's just go on here
and we'll come back to this okay so
Roger you understand I I you know kind
of
do you understand no it's the question
of how we knit it in with everything
else I understand that and fine bring
bring in the people we'll we'll reason
through it fine but but just my point I
hope the knitting will not override the
main aim of the function which is
essentially to for somebody to easily
have the object on this device or I mean
on on his phone it doesn't really matter
that he goes to the cloud or we
magically push it to whatever way well
but
foreign
how else would you get it to your phone
no that's I mean the only part right now
is to the cloud like definitely
but I mean I just don't want you to
dominate the whole design
well
I'm sorry but you know that's the whole
point the fact that there is potentially
another way to do it like a direct
Bluetooth connection or who knows what
else right
um
yeah I'm thinking here
uh
okay hey Marcy is is Todd going to come
or not
I'm still trying to reach him
I won't give the introduction without
without that but so let's keep going
um
okay
great obj so so how do I make the teapot
be um uh be in color
um so we are still working on it not yet
on your build but you know
if we we are trying to we will preserve
the you know the look and the feel of
our Graphics so this is what we are
working on now
for example what about Geographics
well that that should also be exportable
the other forms of Graphics like
Geographics Astro graphics and so on
right
in principle if we can just yeah we just
change it to a pure graphicobject and
it's about that yes
and I think you should be able to export
any expression and just rasterize it
why not
yep that can be the default case we make
exception like entities where we have
polygons and such we might be to
appropriate things yep yes
right okay
what the heck is Target system
well it's like
um no that that cannot be right we we've
had canonical names for these before and
that's not it
iOS find out what dollar system maybe
Joel knows that what's dollar system ID
for iOS
that I don't know okay I think our node
would know that
so Marcy you have to chase him to find
that out okay
okay we will have had that when we've
got certainly for Android we had that
because we had an Android kernel
uh is it called iPad OS I've never heard
that
yeah it is now
it is
yeah it was iOS for the longest time but
a couple of years ago they created an
explicit iPad OS okay fine
okay is Target system the right option
to use for that deployment mechanism
Target system is what we use for like
GPU CPU right yes yep
probably okay
and in the future
if this
you know what you should support
alternative values there that are just
the file types
right
you said I'm saying
instead of saying iOS just say USD or
something
oh okay I see
and maybe we have it already a thing
export formats don't we already have an
option for that
that's called because the reason I'm
saying this is imagine somebody comes as
they will and they said I've got a great
new in fact I even saw somebody pitching
this to me like within the last two
weeks some kind of immersive device type
thing right
and it's like oh we take gltf format
right it'd be nice to be able to use
this function
and expect that it works for that or
maybe they have some other you know
fancy
you know format type
that they take and then it'll be nice to
be able to
well we what we have to have no actually
what we need here is the dispatcher
directly analogous to URL dispatcher we
need something that says given that this
is your operating system this is the
file type to use or this is the file to
use am I correct
um yes it's kind of what we have behind
this scene yes right which is exactly
URL dispatcher is that how you
implemented it
um not has your dispatcher no but but
you could yep
I think
well essentially what you're doing is
you're dispatching on the user agent
type yes
but so what we really want here much
like in the case of interface switched
right well we're getting a if you have
this use that type thing by making sense
yes
um
I think this is a little bit different
in its Behavior oh look it's it asks for
the user agent string here
um
what exactly are you using to dispatch
on you're not parsing the user agent
string are you you're using what we have
but the device type that we've gotten
from the user agent string is that
correct
well it is the user agent some
undocumented Cloud sample I use
what is it
um well
what do you think it should be
it's likely to be dollar user agent
something operating system or browser
name I think user agent
okay
well but we whatever it is better not
change well once we're using it for this
and maybe we should document it
yes user agent operating system yeah
user operating system I I would actually
get a raise a suggestion to consolidate
all those fields into a single thing
like dollar user agent that's just an
association I think that'll be a better
idea yeah
I agree can you do that quickly I mean
yeah
like for 13-3 right yeah
let's try to get that and and go through
Todd for the design I guess and then
make sure Charles is aware and can use
what you're what you've built
[Music]
okay
so
okay are we getting told or not
neither Kristen or I have been able to
reach him yet
Joel who else would would have an
opinion about how to do uh uh you know
we've got this different form of cloud
publishing and so on with a different
kind of object that's being published
who else would have an opinion about
that
[Music]
um
I mean
are you the person what's that people
like Ricardo might have some of the all
the people who are in the previous
meeting that was such a horrible meeting
um
well okay
so when it comes to color Stephen
so I think there's a couple of things to
be aware of
uh that's sort of two kinds of file
formats there's ones that kind of the
older Geometry The obj Format has just
geometry and some of the ones have have
surface color
I mean yes I've had the experience of
trying to get things 3D printed and
having people tell me oh we just don't
do color on you know we don't do any
surface colors right
exactly
um but some of the more modern ones you
know like this USD they have a full
Shader uh layer you know it's pretty
rich actually
okay so we just have to be able to
Output to that
yeah so our goal is to both you know in
the future to be able to export
basically the shaders that we use
um it's kind of like our light system
plus but this version we should just be
able to Output our standard you know
faceted polygon colors yes
yes well we'll guarantee that we'll
export the geometry correctly and
probably some base busy color and maybe
some light right
Okay but well you know but but going a
few further into the future the our goal
is to export better visual fidelity
meaning that I understand that but if
it's a if it's a furry creature then you
can export it with fur right yes okay
all right I think Todd is here now so
let's describe the issue okay
okay this is super cool thing that these
guys have that allow you say AR deploy
loves to check because Todd is here yes
yeah
um you say AR deploy of a piece of 3D
geometry and hold up your phone to the
screen and go to this and you'll get a
floating teapot
okay
that works by two people Point your
phone to this
all right okay so it works by having
deployed several files to the cloud
um
presumably in the directory defined by
that uuid
correct
Charles yes
and all of this stuff here is garbage
right it's just a uuid followed by Sub
Sub sub names is that correct yes this
shouldn't be here right that's just
because of the development process
correct
um yes exactly we didn't want to dump it
in any arbitrary thing so it's yep
correct well it shouldn't be dumped
anywhere it's just the uuid
right and the axiomatic theory of the
universe is uuids never collide
okay
amusingly really is actually related to
the universe because we have these atoms
of space that are you know unique
but you can't prove their uniqueness
from inside the universe anyway
different topic
um
okay so so I think it should be and Joel
do you see any objection to that they
just generate a what would they do to do
this they generate a uuid and then they
put things into the then they would
deploy to subdirectories of the uuid is
that right
Joel Hi
sure
well is that is that a sensible process
does that make sense and if they delete
that base you you ID does it delete the
things the the sub pieces yeah we have
something called an external bundle that
is a well you just make it a directory
too that's that's a new ID but well what
does if it's an external bundle look we
need a specification for these guys
where they should put this and there's
no reason for this okay people could put
it in a in a personally named file or
directory okay that's called teapot or
something in the home director or
wherever they want it okay but by
default it should just go to an
anonymous
uuid
uh
place
right yeah and with no arguments like
you're showing it here that's what will
happen no but it's not what will happen
that they wrote this specifically and
it's going in this person's crazy bass
temp AR directory okay so which is well
what I'm saying what I'm talking about
is the cloud publish AR dispatcher XXX
that syntax just universally will create
by default creates a an anonymous Cloud
object uh identified so they should put
okay if they put their files they have
three files right is that correct guys
Okay so
actually you have four files
because you have your dispatcher which
is not the same as the dispatcher that
is part of
um you know so they need an external
bundle do they not
it sounds like a uh similar to document
generator and auto refresh
okay but so so then
and that external bundle will then be
referenced by one Cloud object
is that correct yes so if they delete
that cloud object it all goes away it
all goes away yeah okay so then let me
explain the rest of the plumbing so they
have something where when you point your
phone at this thing
it
serves you the URL that is appropriate
for your type of phone
do you see what I'm saying
okay because because they're different
file types for iOS and for Android
I see okay now in principle you could
pick up other things from the user agent
string to use in that dispatch
dispatching
I mean then then you have to do it
custom well what else might you I mean
you might I don't know you could have
something depending on geolocation or
some such other weird thing
right I mean you could you know the the
the IP address of the incoming phone
right guys yeah
so in principle you could dispatch on
more stuff
so you might want in the deployment
function you might want to dispatcher
that could be a little bit richer and
use other things
just for extra weirdness
you know like like it can know whether
you're a night or day for example I
don't know why that matters but it might
matter
does that make sense Charles and Roger
yeah
okay
so I don't see an urgency too no no
there's no way right now I'm just trying
to get a design I'm just yeah
um okay so now
this okay so
Todd and Joel you understand that what
they need
is
a piece of code
running in the cloud
actually it's quite unclear to me why
okay how what's the best way to
implement this they have a a front piece
of code running in the cloud that simply
looks at the
um user agent string
and then serves them one of these three
files
I mean that could just be a raw piece of
code what's that
Yes actually if you like you say
essentially right now white essentially
it's a you know we do a cloud deploy a
of a
you know just a switch of user agent and
then we just redirect to URL so
essentially it's you know two files yeah
plus a cloud object although they don't
actually need to be filed I mean you
could deploy them as just parts of a
single Cloud object you could literally
say delayed of
and then some you know switch of the
user agent string comma and then one
pile of bits and then another pile of
bits yeah yes plus or minus that's
actually in the detail the Android
requires some more crazy and condition
to make it work so that's why we needed
the
redirection
okay so look
Joel and Todd could you help these guys
to get that implemented in the right way
sure so so right now this doesn't exist
this this this barcode is just generated
by hand or something I I don't
understand no no no everything is
implemented it exists the question is
what's the correct administrative way to
fit in with the cloud system
right and
that sort of future proof and which is
practical and all of that right it's
spraying three or four files
in with with a hierarchy
enter the cloud file system okay
and so the thing is first what should it
spray into the cloud file system that's
first question
right
that's
so that
It Is proxied by a single Cloud object
So when you say delete object it will go
away
making sense
yeah but it sounds
what happens if there's a high polygon
count
I mean
it can be a rich object
I mean this thing could be a 50 megabyte
file
yeah so it matters that you can delete
it
yes
okay
sorry go ahead what you told you were
going to say something
um
I was going to say that it sounds Joel
you're saying the external bundle is
already
this thing that they want well it's I
mean it close it's it's close it's it's
um essentially just a directory that has
a cloud object that serves as the the
entry point to it so when you request
that
that object it can run this delay
and that's great that's what they want
yeah and then and then they can put
other things underneath underneath it
I think that's exactly what they want
yeah sounds sounds exactly right
uh Bob s has also got some experience
with kind of hooking into the cloud
deploy slash cloud publish
there's some um up value that you set to
get it sort of recognized by some parts
of the system
um just as another resource but it can
certainly be a point of contact
right so so this is what they would do
it looks exactly like what they have
right now they just deploy as an
external bundle and then everything will
just work
then then that API function has to
reference the things in the same
external bundle and I don't know exactly
how it does that
but that's what you guys have to figure
out
so Marcy you you understood that Bob s
needs to be connected to these guys
yes
okay so let's come up with a name for
the thing which would actually show up
in the uuid
right uuid followed by something here
and that name has got to be something
like AR dispatcher
or ar viewer what do you think the right
name for that is
it's the thing where when you go there
it serves you the right thing
right so it's not a viewer right there
the viewer is in the thing that you have
AR object
yeah
could be
all right
so AR object
tentatively
because that's what you'll see it's oh
what is it it's an AR object
right
okay so now let's talk about what it
looks like
when you
publish this so the thing
that you need to get back
okay when you do Cloud publish you
always get a cloud object back true or
not true
the display of the cloud object can
contain weird stuff as it does for mail
receiver function true or not true
um
find weird stuff but well I mean they
need to get back a thing which displays
the barcode
so you're talking about what happens
when you visit the URL on the clock okay
no no not when you visit it no I mean
this works we can easily that cloud
object can be baked into that other
object that we have so it doesn't have
to be exactly Top Line thing right but
the point is that
the deployment there
should have I mean the the idea is you
literally you get back into your
notebook
this thing with a oh the typeset thing
okay yeah that types that thing with a
QR code
I mean that you know you do a AR deploy
and then you just get the cloud object
with the QR code right instead of the
you the long URL no no I understand that
I understand that so this will be an
alternative okay so that's an
interesting idea that cloud object could
have some kind of option
that causes it to be displayed as a QR
code rather than as the URL that might
be useful in general
yeah actually
why are we using
why do we want the cloud object returned
not some other wrapper that contains the
cloud object and the barcode and
displays okay we could do that the the
the disadvantage of that the thing I'm
concerned about is we're going to need
to deploy a publish whatever and I don't
want to replicate you know our publisher
or deploy seems very weird right but all
we have already don't those objects
those functions Cloud publisher can't
they already take things they could just
operate on this head this object yes the
question is what is it return yeah Cloud
publish always returns a cloud always
returns I see so we we have counterparts
for this in in like create Cloud
expression and
uh maybe permissions group
that have their own Creator deployer
functions that return something with a
different head
so it's not you have to give it an
expression anyway but
and and it's it's critical for cloud
expression because the way you use it is
completely different from any other kind
of object
right that's why it's an exception
with a delete object works on it and but
delete object works
okay so let's come back to this okay so
the the options are
AR deploy AR publish two functions and
an AR deployment
or actually AR object will be the
consistent thing
right so the the one possibility is that
we have explicit layout because people
are going to want both the deploy case
and the published case in my opinion
and you think of
which one is private of these two
deploy
publish has the public
root
yeah
and then these would probably create
an AR object
though because it's really an AR it's
really a cloud object okay so plan B
would be
that we have a new thing here that is
called where you say cloud publish
of
AR
okay here's a here's an interesting
suggestion maybe
what about Cloud publisher AR of
graphics
that then returns a cloud object
whose format has been set so that it
displays its URL
as
a
in this form
do you see what I'm saying so Cloud
object right now Joel I think didn't we
put in these things that specify the
format in which the cloud object your
name formats and URL types yeah
okay Cloud object name format
so that could perfectly well say we
could have a setting for that that just
says QR code
could we not
because that that affects just the print
form correct
that true it affects the print format
should be
format yeah it's just the printful right
it's it the question of how the URL
looks is probably after this because the
the name format
actually changes the URL
it could be by uuadier
okay fine we had another thing yeah
right so we need another the not a cloud
object display format
yeah
okay so it could either be and it could
be in fact that will be useful anyway
because sometimes you just don't need to
see the freaking you know you could just
say iconized or something it's just a
blob and you just click it to get to it
all right so Cloud object display format
okay I kind of like this what do you
guys think Roger what do you think of
this
what um
so it's a kind of a rapper is what
you're saying pure rapper that says make
this an AR
I mean
I don't know what else we'd say AR what
yeah hey our object there I mean and you
know this is nice and short
so then that would go in the when we
have Cloud deploy
right there's a Motley collection of
things that you can deploy
oh
right each one is lodged in the server
in a different way
I see
okay
um
just thinking of what else one would use
that rapper for but I can't immediately
but we don't have anything right now I
mean I think that potentially
that rapper
and and inside that wrapper you can put
all these things like the formats you
want and you can put other you know
details like a maximum polygon count or
something whatever the hell you want
there
if you see what I'm saying
I mean the whole point is you need that
because otherwise if you just have a 3D
graphic there
it doesn't know that this is what you
want it doesn't know you want to go
augmented reality with it
yeah I mean that that is to give
Cloud published or knowing what to do
right instead of having a different
function
but then
Cloud deploy can also work on the same
wrapper itself but that's the whole
point so the whole mechanism of
permissions and Publishing and
deployment and you know all that stuff
and auto refreshed and so on everything
would just work
Auto refreshed
professional I gotta learn more about
the cloud so Auto refreshed is something
where let's say that the that the thing
you're well I mean I'm not sure that
that would work in this case but but you
should be able to wrap okay so here's an
interesting question
okay let's say you want to do the
following
let's say you have an API function
that wants to return something
that is one of these AR
well I guess you just do that too yeah
you just do that because you have to
have a secondary publishing
so your API function would then contain
Cloud publish of AR or whatever else
yeah they would do the same thing as we
as you do in top levels what do you mean
right but I mean in this
so here what you would do is to get out
the QR code you would just say this
thing here you'd have a sub value to the
cloud object we have sub values to Cloud
objects don't we
I don't think we do but I want I I've
started with information
we have information now right so we
could certainly put QR code into the
information
right and then these things could become
sub values as well
that makes sense
they are head that you're talking about
does this exist only as a queue to Cloud
publisher does it have some other use in
the system
well I'm not sure yet I mean I what else
could it I I can imagine that it has
other uses in the system like
um
I mean it is
it is like rasterize
it's a way of converting I mean
okay spherical image for example
how would you get
wait a minute
you know for example you want to make a
spherical image
I don't know I mean I'm not sure
Roger Charles how what else could that
be used for
well I mean there was also I mean like
earlier the ardplayer have different
targets right I mean right now it seems
like all our faces this is on the you
know the cloud side but is is possible
that there is a different part later on
with you know a different device she
doesn't go through the cloud right or
we have a completely different process
right
right but the whole point here is that
we would then support whatever it is
service X you know service execute or
something of this thing which would send
it to some bizarre you know
I don't know sort of
um
you know VR Dome or something whatever
the heck it is
I mean I remember about three years ago
I was I was using it was unbelievably
messy but I was sending things to the
oh what was we're using a Vive
I was trying to send you remember that I
think you probably helped with this
Charles I was sending
um
uh stuff for the physics project
to be able to visualize hypographs
um yes how did that work how did that
actually get sent to the Vive
it was very messy as I recall
what well I don't know what was
iteration after that but the first
prototype was through the unity link
where you essentially you know building
the whole scene
and generating the code for that's
really freaking crazy
I mean yes I don't think there was
another iteration I think we gave up at
that point
but is there a more modern way of doing
that using these using this gltf format
and things
um
don't yet have those Direct parts
or maybe I need to explore more Avenger
check but
okay
okay but
all right so one question is whether to
be more defensive in the naming of AR
here
right it doesn't seem useful to have
this symbol if it only is used to signal
to Cloud publish and Cloud deploy that
this should be done they need a signal
they need a signal well but I mean if
this head is useful onto itself as a
rapper General rapper in the system then
great but if it has no no and I guess I
guess it probably will be used for some
things no no but but Todd my point is it
needs to be some signal to Cloud publish
well well the alternative would be ar
publish right AR deployed
which I don't like very much because
they're giving you a
I see AR published that returns a cloud
object yeah right we just it's just we
don't need to invent but then we have to
have two other symbols a published AR
deploy it just seems a little weird to
use this AR rapper head only as a just
as a hint to Cloud publish but but I
suppose it probably API function is only
a hint to Cloud publish as well
well I mean I admit okay well you can
API function you can use directly in the
system you can use it directly and you
can use it in generate HTTP response
which which is something that you could
use for other types of web server
situations which you could also use for
this presumably
that's let's see is that right
um I think so if this thing is yeah it
should work the same way it should
produce its bundle
and then you can deploy it not in the
cloud so so
the bundle is cloud specific
um yeah this is where I'd want to ask
Carlo how he would think of this for
generating fun but I mean but that's a
good point that being able to deploy
this
yeah in a way that's connected to an
export format
yes they're inside there is multiple
export formats okay but here's the
scenario you want to instead of using
our Cloud you want to have a piece of
JavaScript that's running on some
generic Apache server
see what I'm saying to do the same thing
I mean I hope you wouldn't want to do
that you might as well use that cloud
right but but and that usage argues for
AR publish
no it doesn't because that's going to
the cloud object because if you say
generate that otherwise you'd need AR
generate HTTP response which is crazy
if you've got this wrapper this L
wrapper you can say generate HTTP
response you can do everything that you
can do with any of the other Cloud
object things
all right I mean
okay how could we name AR a bit more
defensively
I mean in some ways it's kind of XR that
we're doing uh
no it's v r a r m r
what's Emma
mixed reality
okay
well I mean
you know I could imagine something like
then XR rendering
of Graphics or something
actually why does XR form that that's
the same thing that we have with export
form right oh yes yes yes yes yes
remember export form think about export
form was that what you were going for
yeah yeah this is what to do this is how
to do it
see what I'm saying that says that when
you Cloud deploy we want this as a gif
but if you remember that's what I was
pointing out at the beginning that if
somebody know the platform where they
are you are on like right now somebody
knows they understand so then then you
can do Cloud deploy of export form of
blah
wait that's why my point is that this
this part are there right so we can tell
user how to do it and then the best is
to have a separate function with those
not it's not the best thing think about
it look we just went through all the
reasons why that's not a good idea
right because it's got tons of options
about permissions about whether it's a
generate HTTP response going to a
foreign server
Etc et cetera et cetera we do not want
to replicate that for the AR thing
you see what I'm saying we want to
piggyback on what's already there in the
cloud
I agree but somebody can replicate it in
a few line the course is that you know
by embedding it has happened no it's not
going to work Charles it's not going to
work you've got to be able to delete the
object you've got to be able to do all
these things which are all provided by
the cloud system you're not going to
rebuild the cloud system
but what I mean is that in a classroom
right somebody have to just tell to a
kid you know just take your plot 3D and
I will generate it to the you know
export it and look at it on your phone
right so somebody have to start to type
you know Cloud publish of AR of car fix
and generate the cloud object so there's
that I mean programmatically it's nice
you know what you know what
you know the 3D print function
I've tried to use that a bunch of times
it never worked for me never worked
I always have to ask you how to use it
because it's always doesn't quite
connect to the printer correctly does
this wrong it does that wrong
because it was another one of these El
Cheapo things that doesn't go through
our main system
so when things go wrong you you know
you're stuck
I agree it's nice to be able to say
you know just render this
so is it the case that that we're trying
to I'm thinking about like a a function
that's trying to translate
something about the environment to which
format are we rendering to
but something in the in the runtime
environment from the phone
right but I'm I'm trying to imagine how
this could be made you know like more
defensively so I'm thinking of it in
terms of
there's a rendering function or there's
a function that's going to take a
graphic and
an environment like it something
basically a function that translates
from something in your environment to
the export format
and you could provide that for the
different environments Cloud environment
would use user agent but another
environment might use something else in
that function
yes
but I mean that's not the only thing you
might want to do you might want to
reduce the polygon count for certain
devices and things like this you might
want all sorts of stuff going on
is XR published okay if you could have
XR publish for example
as I mean if what we did was to say
there's an XR form
that is like export form
or perhaps it's a version of export form
but it's not because because it's got
mime types and things in it right
am I making sense I mean I have to
believe that there will be a an on
computer version of this before very
long
am I making sense
as opposed to only phones
the VR version will be an on computer
thing right
um I mean they'll definitely be headsets
no but are they going to be Standalone
but what about the following thing if
it's on a computer why are we just
acting you know like we're dead in the
water why aren't we just bringing up a
you know a standard 3D viewer
in other words if you open that URL on
your computer why not
with a 3D viewer
seems like the obvious thing to do
I don't know how you launch a 3D viewer
is there a default 3D viewer that exists
in a web browser for example
but that's what we should look at
go ahead well
so when when you say 3D viewers pretty
much on on the desktop why the view I
just based on the file format so like in
that you know in the first example you I
mean example when you try to open it
from your computer the system open right
in that case we can or unmark have we
just have it we just have a mime type
that's what determines how it opens on a
web browser it's going to open in a web
browser with a mime type
okay so which might what is there a mime
type that will produce a 3D viewer
I think they all need some kind of
plugging I mean or um do they I mean is
that still true I don't know if that's
still true
and I think it is right so for under the
browser by Def for those supports USD or
jtf right
they don't yet I understand they don't
support those yet
right but the question is when you are
serving it to the desktop What DOT you
need to survey dot blah blah blah file
to the desktop and I assume that the
files that you have are the backing
files here are named as dot USD Etc
correct yes and if you open them there
is a month type
so I'm saying for the desktop we should
produce the most friendly most least
ridiculous mime type
right the one where you're most likely
or it's easiest to get a viewer
and if there is one which is has a
viewer by default in in web browsers
that will be great
I'm making sense yep yes doable
there
and that means we don't have to have
that page of the you got here but we
can't do anything with it
unless we think it is so difficult to
get a 3D viewer that that's what we have
to do otherwise you'll go through the
operating system mechanism of there's an
unknown mime type get a viewer for this
right
okay I need to get going in a second
here but but
um but but Stephen were you suggesting
what's highlighted on your screen Cloud
deploy of export form of some 3D
Graphics comma ARS that is what you're
suggesting this should be
well I'm asking could we just do that as
the wait a minute as the manual version
of this you know Exxon or something as
the manual version of this or as the
only version no as the manual version
and then give Charles his XR publish
that will be an El Cheapo version of
this that doesn't do permissions doesn't
do all kinds of other stuff
right
do you get what I'm saying is there an
XR deploy or is it just no there would
not be just be XR publish
and if you want deployment
you know you've got to go and use cloud
deploy of export of export form of that
comma XR
now I don't think we should just call it
XR we should just call it
um
you know
like XR object or something
mirroring the the file extent you know
file name
you see what I'm saying
and that would then deploy as one of
these external bundles
does that make sense to you guys
yeah yeah I mean the the deployment is
an external bundle but is is it the case
do we have file formats that display
deploy as multiple files
in the cloud is there an export format
Roger there are exports export formats
that deploy multiple files two or not it
doesn't even hdf doesn't that have a
directory
USD have directory I mean the whole is a
ZIP file
so I'm asking a different question I'm
asking
hdfs it's all baked in okay all right
but I'm asking in export do we ever
export a directory
HTML does that
HTML does for sure yes okay fine so
we've had a precedent for that so we can
simply say export form of XR object now
then export could also be able to export
an XR object which would be exactly the
same thing that you're deploying to the
cloud as a directory
do you see what I'm saying
right
right which is a nice way so that then
you don't have to go through all of this
Auto Plumbing you can just get the files
sitting right there on your file system
you do whatever you want with them
right makes sense
yes does that make sense Charles
um yes yes but but if you're saying
export just export of some yeah
that's what I'm saying is going to make
a directory that mirrors the but is that
what people want if they're doing it if
I'm just doing this on my desktop
computer no you don't want that we don't
know why you want that yet it's just a
thing you might want okay we don't know
what that's good for right now
okay the more common case would be that
you say cloud deploy of export form yeah
of graphics 3D
comma XR object
and that would then do everything we're
talking about but there would be an El
Cheapo form of this which is XR publish
of graphics 3D
does that make sense
yeah
why am I saving this
geometry
graphics
do you like the name XR publish would
you prefer AR publish
and I assume we want a default to
publish it I don't think we want to
default to deploy it because in your
scenario of a classroom it's not going
to work
to get what I'm saying
um I think publish is the most useful at
least at this stage yeah so do I I think
the number of people who have secret
geometries that they're you know that
aren't you know where they're going to
worry that somebody's going to poke into
their uuid is is very small
okay so Excel publish like publish would
then have a second argument that's the
destination Charles do you have a strong
opinion between EXO and AR
um
not really
yeah I mean
me neither I mean I don't think it's
going to be called when the Apple
headset thing comes out is it going to
be called XR or ar
en't we find out what Apple has been
calling it because I think that's going
to dominate this Market when that
finally appears it just decided to
actually release the product this year
I mean Apple have been always calling it
AR I mean all their stuff it's AR
okay so without being always they are
then maybe we should call there or
object for now
I mean AR seems
so in the meta people you know Oculus
and so on they're there folks right
okay
well I mean AR is certainly the more
popular name for now yes
all right so AR object it is an AR
publish
okay so then Cloud publish has
destinations and so on which this would
inherit
and this is returning AR publish is
returning a cloud object
that will have this extra Plumbing that
Joel is going to implement that allows
you to get the QR code
makes sense
so that means that
that will be basically a one stepper
yes AR publishes a one-step thing this
will return a cloud object which will
just look like
it'll basically return this
yeah oops
it'll look like this
and there's a cloud object wrapper
around it which well that's just life
okay I think we've got a decent design
here
it's pretty cool actually
the whole functionality is very cool
right everything else fine for me what's
that it worked fine for me when I did it
at the start of this meeting
yeah
I do just want to try okay one thing
here just one second
um and I really need to go oh my God
does it need a progress monitor
probably
what's it doing
does it run the different file outputs
are they okay why is that that looks a
little odd
oh that's
right we wanted to kind of put the shape
of the shape of the objectives
why not put it at the default view angle
yeah you should probably restore that we
put front and default on yeah I think
you want the default view angle
um
help how do I do this
camera
wow
well if it wasn't ghostly it'd be
fantastic
wow
the thing is a little bit when I pinch
Zoom the thing
it's a bit fuzzy
is there something with a normal stress
yes yeah you have you need to copy the
normal the color and the rest
can you see that that's a bit
oh right because also the white they
also look at it as a subdivision surface
and they smooth the whole thing so we
need to push the normal to avoid all
that okay focus this kind of thing
weird
okay okay there we go okay so it looks
like one of those things that's been you
know printed 3D printed out of some bad
plastic yeah it looks like it's an
inflatable
I do
might be a good inflatable
this one might be yeah
build a really big one people can walk
around it right kids okay anyway so
minor issues there but it's spectacular
this works
um okay I'm super late I'm gonna be late
to the next meeting I would guess 10
minutes late or something
um which is also a live stream and we're
obviously going to have to come back to
the the remaining stuff that's in this
agenda
right
and unfortunately we are deeply running
out of time because there's a lot of
other stuff going on this week but
hopefully we can
we've got it Roger we have a meeting
this evening maybe we can cover this
then
because Charles is available
let Kristen try and deal with that okay
um
okay
uh actually hold on the
okay a couple of people from our live
stream are favoring XR and Mr and um
yeah
but I think for right now
this deployment and those file formats
if I look up the gltf file format will
it say it's an AR file format or uh
because it isn't a VR I mean it's not
the thing that you feed to it you know
to a Vibe headset or something
right there isn't a way to do that yet
they are just generic um transfer format
right for 3D
yeah but so this workflow is really an
AR workflow
yes
um yeah it really is but the whole point
is that you walk around it you know it's
places it in your environment well
except that I think the more actually
for our purposes the thing that I wear I
was just visualizing the object without
is is also really you know
that's also useful
okay I gotta go thanks guys and uh for
those following these live streams we
will be starting another live stream
probably in about 10 minutes
thanks see ya okay